so my friend Malcolm MacGyver who is an
engineer / philosopher has this theory
that that made a big impact on me on one
of the many steps that probably took
place on the origin of consciousness
which was when fish climbed out onto
land for the first time because he says
you know when you're in the water you're
the attenuation length for you looking
at things is a couple meters and
basically all your little brain needs to
do is see something and decide do I go
toward that or away from it that's all
you have time to do when you climb out
in the land suddenly you can see for
kilometres and now there's a an
evolutionary pressure to develop the
ability to contemplate carefully
separate choices of action you know
hypothetical situations do I you know go
through the forest do I go down the
river or whatever so the need to
contemplate the future in a different
way
is is now selected for and that's one of
the steps that is important - who said
that Malcolm McIver
I can give you the name ma C IV er and
it fits in with something which I think
I learned from Steven Pinker which was
that you know he says that the evolution
of grammar is an important part of
consciousness an important and in
particular the ability to talk in the
subjunctive about possible things and to
make contracts and so forth and there to
bring this back to meaning I think that
you know one of the things one of
pleased to see that one of the concepts
that has been raised often in this
meeting is the second law of
thermodynamics even though it's never on
the agenda but you know one of the
things that I think is underappreciated
in the search for meaning or even for
morality is the idea that what we should
be thinking about is not states of being
but processes if you even wanted to be a
consequentialist who maybe should not be
a consequentialist about where to get to
but about the process through which we
are going to get to this specific kind
of future state and I think it's fits in
with sort of the seeing the dime and
things like that you know it's small
changes in your local state of cognition
can and even if they don't change your
state very well they teach how you
perceive everything the other the other
example that I like of that is
Michael Berube who is a literature
professor he was talking about some of
the political changes after September
11th and he says I know all sorts of
friends who say you know I've been a
lifelong Democrat but after September
11th I'm now outraged by Chappaquiddick
which for the non Americans not
Americans in the audience this is a you
know Ted Kennedy had an event back in
the you yes so Ted Kennedy had this
thing back in the I know but I will
unpack the whole thing so there's a
savant Ted Kennedy crashed in the car in
1970 or there abouts and into the river
and there was a woman with him it was
after a party the woman died a huge
political scandal and because of
people's political sympathies we tend to
sort of you know make excuses for the
bad things that the people we like
politically do and and and increase the
terribleness of what people we don't
like
do so the typical stereotypical
democratic thought about Chappaquiddick
is yeah you know the guy got drunk
something bad happened that's terrible
but it doesn't change the fact that he's
a wonderful legislator that is trying to
fight for a better health care and so
forth where the Republicans would say
this guy is a terrible person how can
you you know hold him up is one of the
leaders of your political party and so
forth and there are people who were of
one mind set before September 11th and
then after September 11th you know
there's this increase in the importance
of the loyalty aspect of our primitive
moral sensibilities so now we're loyal
Americans and for various reasons which
we could unpack that gets correlated
with being a Republican and being
America first and so forth and and
suddenly people's opinion about this
long ago event changed now they were
critical of Ted Kennedy even though they
would have it's mostly a joke but you
know you get the underlying point that
what people used as their purported
rational justifications for having
different beliefs change because it said
true that's based on a poll no that's as
your guide some believe the anecdotal
yeah but you know so that's why I like
the Aristotle's you know pointing
towards your grandchildren even though
I'm not gonna have any grandchildren I
have graduate students maybe that's
almost
but you know this idea that in the
search for meaning we haven't even
talked about whether it's okay to have
meaning as naturalist because probably
we all agree but what kind of meaning
could we get you know maybe it is
something about the process of living
life and knowing that we are very far
from equilibrium and the conditions on
earth and in our lives are necessarily
changing how to orient those changes in
such a way that they move toward
something rather than valorising where
we're going to eventually get
you